good morning everyone we are in a new
topic today as you can see but is new
with an asterisk because graphing is
something we've been doing for years and
years and years but what we've done is
we've sort of amassed all of these
knowledge kind of in bits and pieces and
so what we want to do over the next week
and a half is to really collect that
into one place now one of the reasons
why it's worth doing this now is that I
just want to sort of take you on a very
very short stroll over the last couple
of weeks of content right now I
literally just scrolled back up through
the notes that I've been doing as I've
been teaching you guys and I'm this is
just all sprinkled throughout my notes
and I hope they were sprinkled
throughout your notes as well when
you're working out areas and integrating
clearly your diagram is decisive in how
you often work out you know what what's
the area where is the region what am i
boundary is going to be and all these
kinds of pieces of information in theory
you can work them out algebraically if
you have like a really deep and intimate
knowledge of exactly what these
functions should look like but even for
seasons mathematicians like mrs. Lee's
and I you know the picture is enormous
ly instructive for us and there are
always things which you kind of think oh
I wouldn't have necessarily expected
that you know one of my favorite
examples is over here in the top right
hand corner some of you saw this but a
lot of you didn't because you didn't
look at that other video we provided
this is an area between our two
trigonometric functions and when you get
coffee handed the question in algebra
you're like oh it's an area between two
curves you'll probably start somewhere
and somewhere and there will be some
number of regions defined by the points
of intersection but it's not immediately
apparent until you actually draw the
thing that what you've got here you can
see I've got two regions shaded in pink
and region shaded in yellow it's not
immediately apparent until you draw that
these two pink areas are exactly equal
to the yellow area when you combine them
now that's nothing which is which I go
into detail in that video so you should
go and have a look at it if this is all
sounding new to you but in this topic
graphing techniques we're going to be
going through all the different kinds of
functions
we'd be exception of trigonometric ones
because we're actually gonna spend more
time on that
separately however all this knowledge
and all these different other kinds of
functions which come up all the time
we're really going to drill down into
graphing them so today I'm just pausing
because I can heat like a clicky thing
is that me or you mrs. Lee's okay thumbs
up I will proceed this morning where
we're going to begin is with that family
of functions that is most familiar to
you and that's the polynomials we're
also going to throw in absolute value
functions just because we can I think
now for each of these polynomials and
absolute value and then for the other
families of functions in the coming days
we're just going to look at the basics
first and then what we're going to focus
on is when you take those basic
functions and you can see some of them
who are about to draw them so you might
as well get some corner axes ready to
sketch on what we want to focus is a
focus on is two different ways to
transform these graphs to sort of take
the basic version and then say well what
about if we modify it in this way or
that way there's two particular
transformations we're going to look at
one starts with T and one starts with D
we'll get to them shortly so for
starters let's just get our brain back
in the mode of graphing and I'm just
going to point out now in integral
calculus we've been saying oh you know
the question is find an area evaluate a
definite integral these kinds of things
the graph was not the point what we're
looking at now is the graph that is the
point so where is in the past and I've
said it many times I would say ah this
is just a quick and dirty sketch we
don't need heaps of detail we just need
to see enough to help us in this case
we're gonna have a much more detailed
look and we're going to be more
stringent we're going to be expecting
the shape to be more accurate we're
going to expect you to put on all of the
features and not miss any of them out
because when the graph is the question
then that is the focus so it's not just
an additional tool on the side okay
right so we'll begin with some nice and
easy ones we're looking at polynomials
here and I know we don't think of y
equals x as a polynomial but it is X
raised to an appositive integer power so
it's um it's a power of one so let's go
ahead and just for the sake of it graph
it what are we getting here we're having
a straight line passes through the
origin
and of course it has a gradient of 1 now
if I go ahead and label that as y equals
x that's nice and I can even put in that
zero there to indicate the intercepts
but it is worth pointing out that uh
appearance this graph could actually not
just be y equals x could be y equals 2x
3x 4x depending on what the scale looks
like right so if you've never been
introduced to this idea before it is
really important that somewhere on this
graph if I cannot otherwise tell there
has to be a point a set of coordinates
that gives me a sense of the scale of
this graph like here's a very steep is a
very shallow without any numbers on the
graph particularly the axes I can't tell
right so you just need to point pick a
point that's convenient to you as an
example I know that 1 comma 1 is going
to sit on this line and now that I've
put this point for scale onto the graph
I know this can't be y equals 2x because
it doesn't pass through that point can't
be y equals 3x because it doesn't pass
through that point you get the idea I
call this a point for scale I'm gonna
label it as such now you might hear
other people call this a locking point
because it sort of locks in where the
graph goes but I had to call it a point
for scale because it's a point that
tells you what the scale of the graph is
so there's our y equals x right for the
next one y equals x squared 2 getting a
speed through this even though I could
wait for some more interaction because I
think you're fairly comfortable with
this
this of course quadratic equation is
going to give us a parabola right now
I'm gonna start from the origin here and
I'm going to draw my right hand bridge
actually I can do better than that let's
try again that's more like it okay
there's my right hand part in the first
quadrant and then what I want is a
reflection over there on the left hand
side it's not perfect but it is actually
good enough for me to put all the
information that I need namely our
intercept which in this case is also the
vertex and also like before I need a
point for scale conveniently I could put
the same 1 1 1 is a point that y equals
x squared passes through but I could put
anything else as well I could put say
for example 2 comma 4 and now that I've
popped that in this can't be any other
parabola this has to be y equals x
squared and I should label it as
okay last basic one we're going to have
a look at and we could we can keep on
doing this for a while but this will be
enough for us to start understanding
what those transformations are like was
X cubed so you're going to look very
much like Mike was x squared in the
first quadrant right except steeper so
you're going to get a similar kind of
shape like this right but because X
cubed is you know when you when you cube
a negative number you get a negative
number back unlike an x squared we're
going to go down here into the negatives
like so so this is our familiar y equals
x cubed point again passing through the
origin and let's put one more point on
here just for the sake of it let's call
it too common a that'll do and if you
wondering where am I getting these
coordinates from I'm picking an x value
any x value like really and then I'm
substituting it into my function so you
can see over here when I put in 2 when I
put in x equals 2 I'm getting y equals 2
cubed which of course gives me my value
of 8 that you can see up there in the
top right hand corner so that's y equals
x cubed now we've started off here with
some very very simple graphs because
what we're going to do is transform
these graphs and make them more
complicated see how they result in
changes visually but I do want to point
out of course you will meet polynomials
that aren't so simple you might for
example meet something like I mean put
it in a different color you might meet
something like y equals x squared plus
5x plus 6 and in this case what we're
going to need to do is some
factorization that will help us find the
intercepts and if necessary also provide
a point for scale and the same thing
over with our cubic over there within
the advanced course if you get handed a
cubic it won't be a mess it'll be
something that's relatively easy to
factorize for you so as an example you
might get given y equals x cubed plus 5x
squared plus 6x now if you have a look
at this it's relatively simple to
factorize X out and then you get left
with that quadratic you can see there in
the middle of the page or you can
factorize one step further so that will
give you all the different factors and
you can read off the intercepts from the